[Music]
It's God. It's God. It's
God. It's God.
David Wood and Alex Okconor just had a
fire debate on whether or not Jesus
claimed to be God. And I happened to be
there in attendance. And let me tell
you, it was very entertaining. I enjoyed
it. I think that David came out on top
ultimately, but both sides um argued
interesting points. Now, Alex Okconor,
he came from an angle when it came to
whether or not Jesus pre-existed. And he
used an argument that surprised me. Dave
has already talked about the angel of
Yahweh. And there is the suggestion that
the angel of
Yahweh is
Jesus. That doesn't seem to make much
sense to me. For a start, if you turn to
Hebrews chapter 1, the very first verse
says, "In the past, God spoke to our
ancestors through the prophets at many
times and in various ways. But in these
last days, he has spoken to us by his
son." In these last days, if Jesus is
the angel of the Lord way back in
Exodus, the story of the Exodus, why is
it that Hebrews says he's only spoken to
us through the sun in the last few days?
Now, there are a number of reasons why
this caught me off guard. One is because
the title of the debate is did Jesus
claim to be God? And so you don't have
Jesus directly speaking in Hebrews. And
so I was surprised that Alex went to
Hebrews, let alone Hebrews chapter 1, to
argue that Jesus did not pre-exist. So
I, you know, immediately recognized
this. And like Hebrews chapter 1 is one
of my favorite chapters. It's really the
last place you want to go to try to
prove that Jesus is not God or that he
did not pre-exist his human birth.
Hebrews, the book of Hebrews, period, is
the last place you want to go. And
here's why.
Avery. All right.
Okay. All right. For sure. Uh, what's
going on, guys? So, this is a question
for Alex, man. How you doing, man? Hey.
Um, you mentioned Logic. Yes. Yes sir.
You mentioned uh in Hebrews 1 where you
know God is speaking you know God uh
spoke to our you know you know uh
through prophets now he speaks to us
through his son and you're saying where
was Jesus then you know back then he
should have been active and so you know
regarding Hebrews I want just want to
read you this and get your thoughts on
this. Okay it's Hebrews 11 regarding
Moses. It says by faith Moses and I'm
going just skip down to 25 and 26 for
time. choosing rather to be mistreated
with the people of God than to enjoy the
fleeting pleasures of sin. He considered
the reproach of Christ greater wealth
than the treasures of Egypt. For he was
looking to the reward. So how is it that
Moses can be considering Christ's
disapproval if Christ wasn't around for
him to disapprove?
Yeah, that is a great question. So
Christ there he regarded disgrace for
the sake of Christ as greater value than
the treasures of Egypt because he was
looking ahead to his reward.
Now that's something which I I think
yeah I I think it's a good point. I I
mean of course I can offer a
christoologgical interpretation of this
which sort of says that Christ is
promised as the redeemer of mankind and
we're looking at this in retro where
where's he gone? Oh there you are. and
we're looking just dropped it and left.
And I suppose we're we're looking at
this in retrospect and he regarded
disgrace for the sake of Christ. Yeah, I
do I do think that in this instance,
Hebrews is probably presenting Jesus
as I don't know about the angel of
Yahweh, but certainly we're looking at a
high christologology in in Hebrews.
Yeah. So close.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I see what you're
saying.
All right, let's go to the next question
cuz we only got He's so close, guys. But
I I I have no I I for what it's worth I
have no problem saying that Hebrews has
a high christologology. Uh that that's
not that's kind of that's kind of not an
issue to me. But I think it is
interesting to suggest that as a retort
to the idea of the angel of Yahweh being
Jesus. I think that is an excellent
point. Yeah. Yeah. Great job. All right.
Um
uh you see why you do not want to go to
Hebrews if you're trying to argue
against the preexistent pre-incarnate
Christ which you know you know
thankfully Alex was intellectually
honest enough to concede and say you
know what yeah uh this this does seem to
show that Jesus did pre-exist and it you
know is a good retort against my
argument that Jesus is not the angel of
the Lord. This is a this is a good
retort here. This is he we got a
concession out of Alex Okconor with just
one passage in Hebrews. That's Hebrews
chapter 11. I didn't even I'm We're
going to talk about Hebrews 1. Hebrews
chapter I went to Hebrews chapter 11 and
that showed it. There's so many gems in
the book of Hebrews that shows how
Christ pre-existed that I I I just
couldn't imagine being a Unitarian or
being someone who goes against the deity
of Christ or his claims of being God,
being Yahweh. I couldn't imagine I I
would wish that Hebrews didn't exist. I
would I would wish that the book of
Hebrews was not in the Bible so that I
can hold my my point. I would not go
here. So, we got a concession from Alex,
which is beautiful. It's it's it's it's
amazing. And we see here, and for those
of you guys who didn't understand the
point, we have Moses back in the times
of Egypt, the Bible says that he did not
consider the pleasures of Egypt and the
riches of Egypt to be anything. In fact,
he rather suffer with the people of God
during the Exodus because he feared the
reproach of Christ.
Now you guys saw it. This means that
Christ pre-existed and it was in the
presence of Moses. Moses was aware of
Christ, was in his presence and feared
him, had a respect and reverence for
Christ before we get Christ being born
of a human. Who was that? That's the
angel of the Lord, the messenger of
Yahweh. Now, for those of you guys who
who don't know, angel in the Hebrew is
just Malik. It just means messenger. So,
it doesn't tell you what type of being
that messenger is. It could be a uh, you
know, spirit creature like an, you know,
a regular angel that we know of or a
human messenger, right? Or it could be
the second person of the trinity, the
son of God, right? Who was who we know
is the messenger of Yahweh or the angel
of the Lord. And so, this particular
person reveals himself to be divine. Now
guys, he quoted it Hebrews 1. I We could
have stayed in Hebrews 1. I I just, you
know, wanted to I just couldn't believe
it. Hebrews 11. Good. Hebrews 1 shuts
this down. And you guys know it. We've
been through this. You guys have seen it
yourself. If you've been watching this
channel, you've seen it enough. Hebrews
1, you cannot go to Hebrews 1 and ex and
and think that it's not going to teach
the pre-existing Christ. Look, look.
This is what we have here, guys. In
Hebrews 1, this is how it starts off
with just like how Alex read it, right?
Uh long ago and many times and in many
ways, God spoke to our fathers by the
prophets. But in these last days, he has
spoken to us by his son. Now, this is
where Alex stopped. He stopped there. He
did not quote the full verse. Watch what
the full verse says in verse two.
But in these last days, he has spoken to
us by his son, whom he appointed the
heir of all things, through whom all he
also created the
world.
What? So you mean to tell me in the same
verse that Alex quotes, it literally
says that Jesus pre-existed the world.
And in the Hebrew, it's I'm sorry, in
the Greek it actually means the ages,
the times. Jesus pre-existed the times
and created the times.
Huh? And you go here. No way. And guys,
this is just verse two. Let's keep
going. He is the radiance of the glory
of God and the exact imprint of his
nature and he upholds the universe by
the word of his power. My goodness.
Doesn't sound like some mere man to me.
Doesn't sound like some mere prophet or
some angel. This is God himself, the
second person of the trinity, who
upholds and sustains the universe by the
word of his power and who is the exact
imprint of the nature of the father.
That means that whatever the father is,
Christ is also they have the same exact
nature. This is Hebrews 1. No way. Let's
keep going. After making purification of
sins, he sat down at the right hand of
the majesty on high, having become as
much superior to the angels as the name
as as the name he inherited is more
excellent than theirs. Now, let's keep
going because what the father says about
the son, it's it's done. It's over. I
know it was over already in verse two,
but watch as we continue. But of the
son, he says, "Your throne, oh God, is
forever and ever. The scepter of
uprightness is a scepter of your
kingdom. You have loved righteousness
and hated wickedness. Therefore, God,
your God, has anointed you with the oil
of gladness beyond your companions. Oh,
Avery, it's over. Right there. Boom. You
see? Therefore, God, your God, there's
no way Jesus is God. He doesn't share
the same nature. No. Right. It's
over. No way. You have obviously where
Jesus takes on flesh, humbles himself as
the servant and according to Jeremiah
32:27, God is the God of all flesh. So
when Jesus becomes flesh, the father
becomes his God. That's why in Psalms
22, it says at my weather, at my
mother's womb, you became my God. Right?
So it's once Jesus takes on flesh and
takes on that role of a servant, the
father becomes his God in that sense.
It's not that he's a separate god than
the son or you know they're not separate
but these are there it's his relation
with the father according to his flesh.
Now we see that the father calls him god
exalts him anoints him but what else
does the father say? You lord laid the
foundation of the earth in the
beginning and the heavens are the work
of your hands. This is the father
calling the son Lord and it's quoting
Psalm 102 which is referring to Yahweh
actually. So really the father is
identifying Jesus as Yahweh who laid the
foundation of the earth and worked out
the heavens with his hands. He did it.
He's Yahweh according to the father.
They will perish but you remain. They
will wear out like a garment, like a
robe. You will roll them up like a
garment that will be changed, but you
are the same in your ye years will have
no
end. There we have it, ladies and
gentlemen. Hebrews chapter one, the very
chapter that Alex O' Conor went to to
try to disprove the pre-incarnate
Christ, actually bolsters the pre
pre-incarnate Christ with no doubt.
David Wood did an amazing job
demonstrating how Jesus claimed to be
Yahweh and pre-existed his human birth.
And the writers of Hebrews as well
clearly lays out that Jesus pre-existed.
So there's no reason for anybody to
doubt if they just read. Forget
interpreting. Forget
interpretation. Forget trying to come up
with your own thing. The only thing we
do around here, y'all, is we just
read. Oh my god. Logic.
[Music]